Well,
it all started in 2007 when I was lucky
enough to have a full on medical level
of depression.
I'm really,
really bad.
I talk about it in some sort of detail
in the,
uh,
in the book I realized it's actually a
level of which I don't even,
I realized I wrote about it with details
of my youth.
My wife doesn't know.
There's a weird privacy thing that
sometimes happens when you're talking to
know dictating into a computer that you
kind of like this just between me and
the computer and now I realize it's
probably the most public thing,
but the thing that saved me,
the thing that ultimately helped me deal
with my depression in general was
cognitive behavioral therapy.
I'm,
in a sense,
it's sort of like applied stoicism.
You just look at your own thoughts back
to the really exaggerate once you've
labeled them as cognitive distortions
that these include things like
generalization,
catastrophizing,
binary thinking,
thinking,
everything has to be there,
all good or all bad.
I'm actually particularly guilty of
these.
Yeah.
And Amazingly,
if you just actually learn what these
distortions are and practice every day
to sort of talk back to sort of the more
anxious or depressed voices in your own
head,
it's an incredibly effective treatment
for depression,
anxiety and it changed,
absolutely changed my life.
Meanwhile,
as this is changing my life,
I still work.
I'm still the president of fire,
which means I defend free speech and due
process and academic freedom on campus.
And um,
and while I was learning all of these
intellectual habits,
all these ways to sort of talk yourself
down,
I was looking around at what
administrators were doing and saying to
myself,
wow,
it's actually kind of like the
administrators are saying,
oh by the way,
do engage in cognitive distortions,
do engage in binary thinking,
do overgeneralize and most of all,
catastrophizing all the time.
And I remember thinking somebody will be
affected as well.
Thank goodness the students don't seem
to really be buying it.
And that's what changed in 2013,
2014 prior to 2013,
2014 since I started in 2001,
the worst constituency for free speech
on campus was actually administrators
best,
most reliable fans of free speech you
could run into on campus were generally
the students themselves.
And then sometime around 2013,
2014,
we saw a,
suddenly there were demanding everything
from trigger warnings to microaggression
policies to December for even people.
But,
but both on the left and the right on
the spectrum.
And it seemed like we said it seemed to
happen almost overnight and this and
when I went to talk to John About it,
now we've become friends through mutual
friends.
And I said it's almost.
I talked about my whole theory that
we're teaching a generation the habits
of anxious and depressed people from
cognitive behavioral therapy.
John got really excited about the idea,
um,
and asked if I wanted to write about it.
And I was already a fan of John's work.
So I was like,
absolutely.
Yeah.
So I thought that his,
his insight into what had changed was
absolutely brilliant.
I had just begun to notice this in my
own teaching.
I'd been teaching since 1995 at
University of Virginia originally,
and it was seemingly overnight,
right around 2014.
These new ideas,
students,
of course,
political,
they protest,
they object to things,
but what was new grid?
Put his finger on it.
What was new was the idea that these
words are going to harm me,
not just defend me,
not just be unjust.
Pardon me?
We have to protect.
It was this idea that students are
fragile and need protection and the
protection should come from
administrators,
from adults.
That's what was new and disturbing.
Yeah.
Will you guys talk in the book about
Concept Creep?
Hmm.
The overgeneralization of the idea of
trauma.
You know,
one of the things that's really struck
me as interesting about the safe space
movement and the microaggression
policies and all of that is that it does
run so contrary to what every clinician
worth his or her salt,
those about treating anxiety or
depression
and
so,
so that's kind of a remarkable.
A phenomenon in itself is that what we
know clinically has been absolutely
inverted by people who are
hypothetically agitating on the part of
students' mental health and it's not as
if the mental health community has stood
up on moss and denounced this.
So.
And I also don't.
I don't understand that.
I also don't understand how we got here.
You guys talk in the book a little bit
about your little bit of.
You hypothesize a little bit about the
internet generation.
Right?
And those were the kids born after 1995.
You don't put the finger on the
millennials but.
But let's talk a little bit about why
you think things changed in 2013.
In 2014.
Let me just first say your point about
these new ideas are not clinically
supported.
Something that we suggest in the book.
We don't know.
We don't know if this is going on.
To what extent is this a sincere desire
for protection and a sincere belief that
students are fragile and to what extent
is it the pursuing of a political agenda
and,
and making political points and using
mental health as a cover?
I think both are operative and,
and so,
and it may depend on the context.
Why do you think the first one is
operative?
Because this runs so contrary to
everything that's known about the actual
protection of mental health.
I'm very skeptical about attributing a
positive motivation to it.
Like it seems to me that it's
fundamentally driven by resentment.
Well,
it's so,
uh,
so you're absolutely right that the
psychological community does not support
this,
but yet has not stood up very vocally to
condemn it.
So we are hopeful that psychologist and
psychiatrist,
everyone we spoke to agreed that
wrongly,
that's exactly the worst thing to do for
someone who suffers from ptsd,
is to sweep their daily life of
reminders,
thereby denying them the chance to,
to,
to the situation,
to decondition the,
uh,
the power of these triggers in the real
world.
It's worse in some sense because one of
the things you do when you expose people
who have anxiety disorders to the things
they're anxious about is not make them
less anxious but make them more
courageous.
Yeah.
Right.
And that's why generalizes because the
psychoanalysts thought that exposure
would just mean the fears would pop up
somewhere else,
but they don't and it's because people
learn that there's more to them than
they thought,
and then when you protect them,
not only do not expose them,
which is a big problem,
but you also teach them to generalize
the idea of their weakness,
which is a really terrible thing to do
to people.
So you couldn't invent a more
counterproductive mental health
movement.
And instituted on campus is if you set
out to design it.
That's something that we always try to
emphasize and so interesting for us to
look at was the one thing,
because you know the third anti free
speech movement is coming from students
in the relatively recent past,
so late eighties and early nineties for
example.
But the thing that was so striking was
that they were medicalizing all,
all of these claims,
of course,
they're sitting there going like,
that doesn't sound right.
And I talked to John and he was like,
And we interviewed for the original
article,
maybe seven different,
the clinical psychologists,
cbt experts,
uh,
you know,
for example.
And the thing I keep on trying keep on
explaining it as it's,
as a fraternity of what could be a minor
version into something more like a
phobia because we're giving it so much
more power.
And the worst thing of all that we're
doing so much of our campuses,
we're turning it into a Schema.
We're turning the idea that I've broken
into,
um,
into.
It's a permanent sort of self
definition.
So that's why I do think that there's
sort of a mixed motive thing going on
here.
I think that we have a self fulfilling
prophecy going on to some degree because
I do think that some of this kind of
hopeless ideology,
he's actually genuinely Harvard students
actually making them more anxious and
depressed.